last week after 11 years as a pro player
Bjergsen retired we've kind of been here
before because it kind of happened
before but this time it seems like it's
forever in a candid message to his fans
the contender for the goat of North
American League of Legends explained why
he plans on leaving the game and Esports
for good
[Music]
all right before we get into the video I
want to let you know we partnered with
Qualcomm Technologies and the team over
at Snapdragon Le gaming to explore the
world of mobile Esports our latest worth
episode explores the story of Bobby and
OG two of the best brawl Stars players
in the world but before they teamed up
they truly hated each other they had to
overcome their differences to prove that
the greatest of enemies can become the
perfect team you can check out that
episode using the link in the
description box below so Bjergsen where
to begin well we could start with my
Bjergsen shirt which I'm wearing for
this video but you can't really see it
very well but let's start at the
beginning of his career Bjergsen started
his career in Earnest way back in 2012
with Copenhagen wolves although he was
just 16 years old his Raw Talent was
obvious already by the following year
he'd been picked up by TSM to become
their star mid laner everyone suspected
he would do well but even Bjergsen would
have blushed if you told him what was to
come TSM set about dominating the next
four years of the nalcs winning or
coming second in every split and
Bjergsen was always at the center of it
all no matter
range on the fight there's a blade of
the Rune King though they're able to
take down musk boy Bjergsen comes in
there's the shot there's the triple
could that be the Quadra and Bjergsen
picks up a beautiful play but despite
the weight of his fans team and region
on his shoulder bergson always kept a
level head and stayed humble even when
the goat called him Opie
yeah yeah I think he's okay
you here
yes secret of me okay
yeah maybe this year 2020 yeah the TSM
Golden Age didn't last forever though
and after 2017 the Championships dried
up save for their summer 2020 title
where Bjergsen had enemies Perma Banning
his zillion but even that glimmer of
hope was tainted by a biblically bad
world's performance where TSM failed to
pick up a single win across the entire
tournament and at this point people were
speculating about whether he would leave
TSM in his Chase for international Glory
but then he made a very surprising
announcement I'm here to talk about the
fact that I'm retiring as a professional
player and stepping into the head coach
role for TSL in some ways this moved to
a coaching role made total sense
Bjergsen was an experienced natural
leader who already had the trust of his
team with Bjergsen as their coach TSM
performed well in the regular season but
just seemed to crumble in playoffs
jurgson then unretired from playing to
join tsm's longtime Rivals Team Liquid
fans were about to see Bjergsen play
without TSM for the first time in nine
years but despite some decent regular
season form Team Liquid couldn't win
when it really mattered resulting in the
team failing to qualify for worlds for
the first time in five years and then at
the end of last season Bjergsen moved
200 thieves joined by an unretired
double lift the veterans finished third
in the regular season but were
dispatched in the first round of
playoffs just sucks that we couldn't
pull through I think we
uh we had a lot of problems and we kind
of band-aided those problems by playing
a very one-dimensional and predictable
playstyle and draft and
that's going to get harder and harder
towards playoffs when we have so many
lock bands we have very obvious pick
order and champions and kind of a play
style of draft that we're willing to
play and um I think to win a
championship
you don't have to be able to play
everything but you need to be less
predictable than we were in that recent
interview with Travis Gafford Bjergsen
sounded reflective but not dejected
that's why it came as such a shock when
last Friday he made this announcement I
want to make this video personally
because I want to talk to you guys about
the fact that I am stepping away from
League of Legends and Esports in general
and and why Bjergsen made it clear that
this decision was nothing to do with his
teammates or recent results it was
something that had been coming for a
long time after an astounding 11 years
as a pro player bjergsen's experience
something that a lot of us can relate to
he's changed I've been playing League of
Legends for probably like half my life
at this point
it just doesn't feel as fulfilling as it
did when I was younger just spending all
my time playing League studying league
and just chasing winning above
everything else the way I see it is
either you really enjoy the day-to-day
of practicing preparing and competing
every single week or you are really like
sacrificing your love for the game and
enjoyment of competition for the long
term of trying to work your ass off to
win a championship or win an
International Tournament and
I think just
neither of those really are resonating
with me anymore he then touched on
something that we all know about him
he's an absolute Workhorse Bjergsen
always had raw mechanical skill and an
ungodly ability to control his Lane but
what really set him apart from the
competition was his absolute Devotion to
keeping up with the evolving game Lee
can be a brutal game in this sense it's
core objective to destroy the enemy
Nexus has always remained the same but
almost everything else has completely
changed beyond recognition over the
years it's difficult for the average
player to keep up with and that's only
Amplified at the pro level where
longevity is often correlated with how
much of themselves they're willing to
give up I worked harder than a lot of
people and I wanted it more than a lot
of those people and I was willing to
sacrifice you know time with friends
family personal interests Hobbies
personal Curiosities really just
anything for a long time I've kind of
felt and even told the people around me
that if I didn't feel like give my
absolute all towards winning and
towards being the best and felt like I
could be one of the best players in the
world
um that then it would be time to stop
and um it feels like that time is now
what more can you say that is a Winner's
mentality you don't start something
unless you have the desire to win and
you finish if that ever goes away so is
this really good buy well there's
definitely a little bit of deja vu with
all of this I thought Bjergsen was gone
for good when he retired back in 2020.
even when he moved to a coaching role it
seemed like his playing days were behind
him but then we had two more years of
them well Bjergsen explained that he
didn't really see that first retirement
as a retirement at all he feels that
that was simply a roll shift but that
this is him truly stepping away from
League of Legends one thing I found
really interesting in the video was
Bjergsen talking about how League helped
his mental health at a young age it's
something he's touched on in the past
but hearing him say it now at the end of
his journey feels all the more poignant
competing in League of Legends and East
Forest has really changed my life life
in every way imaginable I started
playing professionally when I was 16
years old and it really brought me out
of a really dark place initially League
was an escape for me an escape from
school and being bullied and all my
struggles in life and I never really
felt competent at anything even when I
was playing professional in my earlier
years I felt like
league is the only thing that I'm
competent at or even know how to do so
what is next for the biaga king being
the face of North American League of
Legends definitely looks good on a
resume but how do you follow that up in
a video Bjergsen said he's gonna go away
and figure that one out while spending
time with his friends and family and
that makes sense since he was 16 years
old bjergsen's known who he is what he
wants and where he's going while a lot
of people are always planning their next
goal Bjergsen like athletes and pro
players all over the world has only ever
had one goal in mind winning and when
you're done with that it can take some
time to figure out a new goal that means
as much it goes without saying that
there will be a bjergsen-shaped hole in
the LCS for the foreseeable future
calling someone the face of something
can be a bit of an overused phrase but
not in this case Bjergsen has been a
rock in North American League for over a
decade players and teams have come and
gone in that time but no matter how much
things changed you always knew Bjergsen
would be that he's been a continuous
thread that links to Modern LCS back to
its very Roots I think that his video
sort of is like a reality that like
we're all getting older we all grew up
with each other and in many ways and I
don't mean like me and him are you know
mean anyone I mean like League of
Legends grew up with each other normally
I don't I feel like I don't give two
shits when I read retirement posts or
that someone's taking a break but this
one this one really does bother me on
the rift he'll be remembered in
highlight reels forever for his syndra
Zed azir and of course zillion I
personally think they should just retire
that champion along with him like a
jersey number in the record books he
retires with the record number of total
kills in the LCS and the second most LCS
titles with six right after double lift
with eight and as a person he'll be
remembered for being a humble incredibly
hard-working and decent guy who grew
from a quiet rookie to an inspirational
mentor to those around him perhaps even
Bjergsen himself doesn't know where the
next chapter of his life will lead him
but if it's even half as incredible as
the first he'll be just fine
I was a huge Bjergsen not ashamed to
admit it still am still am I always felt
like he was just untiltable league is
one of the most tilting games ever and
yet this guy playing under all that
pressure just didn't tilt no matter how
bad things were going you always felt
like Bjergsen could pull out the back
and he often did sad to see him go the
na goat